hey this is presh talwalker
on my birthday in 2021 my age is equal
to the sum of the digits of my birth
year
I am less than 100 years old what could
my birth year be
I thank Tuan for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
thank you
this is a tricky word problem so let's
work it out step by step
on your birthday in 2021 mathematically
your age is equal to 2021 minus your
birth year
now since you're less than 100 years old
you are either born in the 1900s or the
2000s let's say you were born in the
1900s then your age is equal to 2021
minus 19 a b but this is also equal to
the sum of the digits of your birth year
and that will be equal to one plus nine
plus a plus b If instead you were born
in the 2000s your age would be equal to
2021 minus 20 a b and the sum of the
digits of your birth year will be equal
to 2 plus a plus b
so let's work out each case in turn
let's start if you were born in the
1900s
so 19 a b is equal to 1900 plus 10A plus
b
so we'll simplify the left hand side
2021 minus that is equal to 121 minus
10A minus B
on the right hand side 1 plus 9 plus a
plus b is equal to 10 plus a plus b
we can now bring the constant terms to
the left hand side and bring the
variables to the right hand side
so we have 111 is equal to 11a plus 2B
where do we go from here
111 is an odd number
and since B is an integer 2B is always
an even integer
so we have an odd is equal to something
plus an even that means 11a has to be an
odd number
now a is a digit between 0 and 9 and 11a
has to be odd so a has to be equal to 1
3 5 7 or 9. so 11a is equal to 11 33 55
77 or 99.
now let's narrow down these cases let's
consider the case that 11a is equal to
77. we would then have 111 minus 77 and
that equals 34.
but this needs to be equal to 2B which
means B is equal to 17.
but you can't have a digit that's equal
to 17 B has to at most be equal to 9.
so we know that this case cannot happen
we also know that 11a can't be equal to
55 33 or 11 because then B would be an
even larger value
so we can eliminate all of these cases
the only possibility that might work is
11a is equal to 99.
in that case 111 minus 99 is equal to 12
that's equal to 2B which means B is
equal to 6.
for 11a to be equal to 99 a is equal to
9. so this gives us a solution of 1996.
so now let's work the other case that
you were born in the 2000s
it will be a very similar calculation
20 a b is equal to 2 000 plus 10A plus b
we simplify the right hand side 2 plus 0
is equal to 2.
so we have 21 minus 10A minus B is equal
to 2 plus a plus b
again we bring the constant terms to the
left hand side and the variables to the
right hand side so we have 19 is equal
to 11a plus 2B
19 is odd 2B is even which means 11a has
to be odd so for 11a to be odd we
basically have one possibility
because 11 times 3 is equal to 33 that's
too large
so we're going to need 11a to be equal
to 11. so a is equal to 1 then 19 minus
11 is equal to 8 that's equal to 2B
giving that b is equal to 4 and this
gives a solution of 2014.
so let's just check these possibilities
if you were born in 1996 your age would
be equal to 2021 minus 1996 which equals
25 and that is exactly the sum of the
digits 1 9 9 and 6. if you were born in
2014 your age is equal to seven and
that's exactly the sum of the digits two
zero one and four
so you were either born in 1996 or 2014
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]